so here we are in front of the palace
just about to go in I've got my periodic
table time so we're ready to go
so we're inside the palace still got the
tie we're about to go inside no filming
inside by us but I'll tell you what
happens afterwards
professor Sir Martin Polyakov for
services to the chemical sciences
so it was really good I spoke to Prince
Charles he asked me about how the green
chemistry was going I told him that we
were making anti-malarial drugs and that
we are now doing green chemistry with
the photochemistry is in life to induce
chemical reactions it seemed very
interesting said he'd like to visit
when I first got my doctorate and was
called dr. Polyakov the only reason that
I found the doctorate useful was to
complain in shops
if you telephoned and said look you this
is not right if you said it was dr.
Polyakov it produced an effect now I
have no idea whether sir will produce an
effect similar effect or whether people
will just love if we are outside the
cameras taking photographs and here is
the man knighthood medal
quite excited
it doesn't look that if it's pure gold
but it clearly has some gold in it